the cup is
sing it
girl mom
no i can't her spontaneity has been
stripped from her
i'm sorry you have such a beautiful
voice
i can't wait to hear it when you're
older will this place stop scuba diving
how does a child have to be to do scuba
diving i don't know trent
i think you're a bit too young you're a
baby you said five minutes technically
it's been way way more than five minutes
are we close
stop wishing away this moment look out
the window look how pretty it is
prisca
work stuff
yeah
lead by actions mom
[Music]
[Music]
wow
this is much better than cancun
[Music]
mr and mrs kappa
welcome to our version of paradise wow
hello
[Music]
so this is madrid she'll take care of
you from your food and beverage
preferences you selected we've made you
cocktails to welcome you
wow
thank you
look
how big you guys are
we have a drink fountain for you too
can we go um
yeah let's go let's go
can you believe i found this online
[Music]
my favorite thing
open 24 hours
candy station oh my god come on trent
[Music]
look what it is mix the vanilla and
strawberry in it
say hi trent
hi
i'm edlin my uncle's the resort manager
here
he's trent i'm addix
i can do a thousand piece jigsaw puzzle
which is a considerable thing to do my
dad and i put clear glue on them and
hang them on my wall
i collect conchos
i have 42 con shells
amazing
i might need a little help with this all
right so we do strawberry manila
thank you
yes
okay
okay i got it okay come on thank you
great job helping
yes
there's 250 000 furniture related
injuries in the united states per year
25 of those
coffee table injuries
hey
fine okay
why the warren must be affiliated with
this resort
we must have conventions here
we love this pharmaceutical company at
work
we're considering asking our clients to
use warren and warren drugs as a way to
lower their insurance rates
yeah
no kids
allowed on the beach what hold on
no kids week that's not true
you should have checked
it's your mom's fault no no no really no
it says there's no you should have
checked it says this yes of course i
know this is very painful news for you
all
there but now now it's in power yes
and you have to do it yes you have to
understand
[Music]
[Music]
what's your name
i'm trent this is
hey nice to meet you
bye
[Music]
hi i'm trent this is it but what are
your names and what do you do for a
living oh well i'm sippy watson i'm a
chef
i'm greg mitchell i'm a cop cool and i'm
mainly mitchell i'm a dancer wow that's
cool okay bye bye
[Music]
go
i don't have friends
i'm your friend
you'll leave my mom might let me
facetime you
then we can be friends you can come over
to my house and make up stories
then we can go to the same college
together
and become neighbors with mortgages
cool
it's weird
i know
it's hanging over me i
can't barely eat
and i don't feel anything
we agreed
we'd give them one last vacation before
telling them
i can't understand why we don't take
into consideration that shouldn't affect
anything
the doctor said it's a non-factor
it's probably been there for years he
said
we were on a course to separate
that's confusing enough for us
let's not bring an irrelevant medical
condition into this
let's get through this guy
compartmentalize
it's only for three days you found the
place
yes
oh briska come on
you're always thinking about the future
it makes me feel not seen
you're always thinking about the past
you work in a god issue
i think they stopped
why don't you play
[Music]
[Music]
you